le 30 novembre un vestige de fusées
lancées en 1966 a frôlé la terre plus
récemment une des plus belles pluie
d'étoilés filantes de l'année les
géminides a eu lieu et malgré
l'impossibilité de réunion de ses
membres
l'astro club de vélizy a continué
d'observer ces phénomènes dans le début
du premier confinement on a reçu
beaucoup de messages de personnes qui
voulaient ils étaient curieux au savoir
qu'est ce que l'on pouvait observer ou
comment commence comment s'abonner à
certaines choses et c'est donc on a eu
une dizaine de nouveaux membres qui se
sont greffées sur notre globe on avait
plaisir d'ailleurs parce qu'on était
très surpris beaucoup ont commencé à
observer le ciel
le club a entamé sa rénovation pour
partager sa passion à tous dans un
premier temps on va améliorer notre
technique au niveau du club
affiné pour qu'il y ait le moins de
couacs possible lorsqu'on diffusera plus
grande échelle accessible via un canal
qui n'ont pas encore défini mais oui
accessible à tous ce qui permettrait
d'avoir des personnes qui sont bien au
chaud chez eux et deux ou trois autres
qui se gèlent rond bien sur place une
passion devenue profession pour certains
l'observatoire de l'ue vs qui devait
fêter ses 10 ans cette année et
l'inauguration de son nouveau bâtiment
des festivités reporter qui n'ont pas
empêché le latmos laboratoire d'étude de
l'atmosphère à poursuivre son activité
dans l'espace cette année on a eu
plusieurs événements
on a un grand nombre de missions
toujours en cours mais cette année plus
particulièrement par ordre on a eu le
lancement du rover persévérance
et donc ça c'est un rover qui va
continuer sur mars a cherché la vie on a
par exemple lépi colombo qui a été
envoyé en 2018 qui va atteindre mercure
et puis finalement là en tout début
d'année prochaine
on a on à la finalisation finalement et
l'envoi d'un anneau satellite ce nano
satellites sera envoyée de californie le
13 janvier prochain afin de mesurer les
radiations sur la terre et provenant du
soleil impliqué sur une quinzaine de
missions spatiales
l'institut compte aussi parmi ses grands
axes d'étude de l'année un sujet un peu
plus terre à terre
on a des projets effectivement qui kills
qui dure et qui permettent d'observer
sur la durée la pollution notamment
c'est le projet yasi
cette année il ya eu des événements
point très important d'une part le
ralentissement de l'activité
industrielle et de la circulation
mais quand on pense astronomie ou pense
aux astres à l'infini à ce qu'il se
passe loin très loin d'ici
on retrouve cette aspiration à la
découverte parmi les futurs projets du
latmos ya une mission tout à fait
intéressante qui est programmé
maintenant avec la nasa qui s'appelle
dragonfly et qui va être un genre de
petits drones qui va aller sur titan
toujours pareil pour essayer de
comprendre l'atmosphère comprendre
effectivement la naissance de la vie de
l'observation sur un toit au télescope à
l'envoi de missions spatiales vers
d'autres planètes
c'est cette curiosité de savoir ce qu'il
se passe ailleurs qui a permis aux
amateurs et professionnels de l'espace
de s'évader tout au long de l'année